you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with Jake Wallace
Simon's editor of the Jewish Chronicle
and Jenny kleeman journalist and
broadcaster they'll both be with us from
now until just before midnight so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now
a winter of Disconnect that's the front
of the Metro after news that the UK
could be facing power Cuts over the next
few months because of a shortage of gas
from abroad
according to the times the cuts are part
of a long-standing emergency plan for
any future energy crisis
the eye says the worst case scenario so
far is for Rolling power cuts of three
hours duration
that uh stories also lead item for the
telegraph
the express 2 makes it the top story
the star says one measure that could be
taken is to pay people to use appliances
at off-peak times hence the suggestion
to wash your underwear in the middle of
the night
but says the mail the money on offer is
only likely to be about 10 pounds a day
the guardian meanwhile reports that
Charities are worried that power Cuts
could mean loss of life for some
vulnerable people
the financial times leaves with comments
from the bank of England that if it
hadn't intervened in the market turmoil
after the new government's mini budget
then Britain would have been on the
brink of a financial crisis
and finally the Sun that leads with a
story about a likely competitor on itv's
I'm a celebrity get me out of here
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Jake
Wallace Simon's editor of the Jewish
Chronicle and Jenny kleeman journalist
and broadcaster welcome to you both let
us start with the metro and I think they
get the uh the prize for the headline of
the day a winter of Disconnect Jenny
I don't really like this headline uh um
but yes this is kind of making us all
remember about the 1970s just when you
thought everything that could go wrong
has already gone wrong uh the National
Grid is now warning that in a worst case
scenario uh there could be uh rolling
power Cuts three hours each we would
have warning of them it would be
different parts of the country at
different times
um I think every year they model
different scenarios going into the
winter they modeled three scenarios this
was uh definitely the worst case and the
National Grid said very unlikely to
happen but of course it spooked
everybody we all feel like we've gone
back to the 1970s with rail strikes and
inflation and uh and now the threat of
rolling power Cuts hence the winter of
uh discontent or disconnect
um but uh we've just got to hope it's
not a cold winter the issue is we simply
do not have enough storage of of gas uh
it's 40 of our electricity is generated
by gas fired power stations and we need
to have more diversity in our supply
very simply this is the issue and
because we don't have enough we are
relying on on gas supplies although we
don't rely on Russia for our gas
supplies
um we are dependent on what happens in
Europe
despite the headline the article is
actually saying that it's unlikely that
there will be a gas shortage isn't it
Jake
that's writing when I read these uh
these stories and the Metro is by far
the by far from far from the only paper
to have this on its front page
um it did strike me that there's a lot
of Hysteria and concern about this and
concern rightly so but it perhaps seems
to be a little bit exaggerated because
uh it does need to be a perfect storm
before these blackouts happen for a
start we need to have a um a cold snap
as Jenny's pointed out then we need to
have a low amount of wind those two
things got to happen at the same time
and then a reduction in the amount of
energy we can import from France uh
Belgium and Holland and only then would
we begin to resort to blackouts but that
would also be accompanied by firing up
three
um coal burning stations which were due
to be mothballed getting them back into
service to cover some of the shortfall
and then we'll be looking at Power cuts
which would be carefully rolled out and
calibrated
um among the population with their
protection so we're told for people who
are vulnerable so I think that to think
that we're going to have uncontrolled
power Cuts occurring at any time of the
day without warning like some other poor
countries in in poor parts of the world
I think is is incorrect it is a serious
situation but let's not get panicking to
uh to to too early but the guardian is
looking at the worst case scenario and
we've got people uh predicting what
could possibly happening they're
suggesting loss of life if those who
need life-saving machines are having to
turn them off for three hours a day so
although what you seem to be saying is
that it's a bit of scaremongering
perhaps this is the likely outcome if we
do get to that that end stage Jenny
well I mean I do think this is a bit
alarmist as well because of course
hospitals are not going to be affected
the guardian's coverage is about people
who require life-saving medical
equipment at home so we're talking about
things like dialysis and uh ventilators
they simply cannot be without
electricity and the guardian does make
the point that the choice that they are
going to be faced with people who rely
on that equipment is whether or not to
go into hospital and be admitted to
hospital which is not a choice you would
want to make certainly if you're a
parent of a child that needs a
ventilator or needs any of this
life-saving equipment you wouldn't want
them to be in hospital when they could
be at home but it doesn't necessarily
mean that lives are going to be at risk
and what this story seems to be is the
worst case scenario of a worst case
scenario uh and I would agree you know
we need to take this with a pinch of
salt the good thing is that we are
wargaming this you know we are looking
at what might happen and and being
prepared for it that's what the National
Grid is for is to look at at all
scenarios it's good that we're having
this conversation now but I do think if
you were walking into a news agent
tomorrow morning and looking at the
spread of front pages you might be quite
frightened
uh Jake do you agree that that we need
to take this particular headline with a
pinch of salt
a pinch of somebody I wouldn't perhaps
have quite put it like that but I do
agree with Jenny that um you know the
the government and the National Grid has
put into place plans to protect
vulnerable households as well as
hospitals and so you know those people
should not be unduly concerned however
this all depends upon the system working
properly and everybody who needs
dialysis machines at home for example is
able to be Exempted from any of the
power cuts that are being rolled out in
their area with the consent of people of
local people but it does require the
system to work I'm not sure that
everybody has uh complete confidence in
the system to protect them at all times
so I can understand why people who do
rely upon machines to to live to sustain
their life uh may be concerned but at
the same time we do need to see it
overall this is like actually very well
put it it's a worst case scenario of a
worst case scenario yes but we could
have seen this coming down the tracks
and and speaking to our political
correspondent tonight Sam coats are
saying that the government had been
preparing for this very scenario but
just hadn't made us aware of it so
people are not prepared and that's
something that the government could have
done couldn't age any prepared people
for this this scenario I think so I
think there's a lot that the government
could have done and other uh countries
have had public information campaigns
for example urging people to use energy
at off-peak times uh not just to save on
gas and electricity bills but just to
eat to even out uh demand and our
government seems to have really shied
away from from doing that and from
preparing people's uh mindset
um maybe they don't want to bum people
out any more than we've already been uh
you know I keep waiting for good news
and for uh things to start to get better
but they really seem to be just getting
uh worse and worse but um you know the
way that we're going to make sure that
things really don't get worse is to be
prepared for every eventuality and the
government could do more to kind of pave
the way for that Jake why do you think
the government hasn't prepared that the
public you know why aren't we being told
to unplug our plugs switch off lights do
our washing it you know out of peak
hours but why aren't we being told this
why why isn't there a government
information film that's being put out
there
I know a variety of reasons for that uh
one of which is that the government's
been quite busy with
trying to survive uh I mean there was
that period when Boris was sort of in
place but knew he was going that seemed
to be characterized by staces at the
heart of government when all this was
brewing and then we had the leadership
election of course and then we had
um you know Liz truss and dealing with
her mini budgets and all that so the
government's been quite quite busy
managing itself let alone managing the
country
um but also I think that the government
has perhaps not wanted to alarm people
and not wanted to um to give advice
about rationing and things which can
really affect people's sense of security
and confidence before it was absolutely
necessary and I think that's that's fair
enough really
um it like I say you know it may be that
we get through this winter without any
of these measures needing to be
introduced and everything could be could
be fine but what the government really
is guilty of over many many years is uh
is not developing a robust
framework within our energy the security
making us too reliant upon importing
energy not enough storage and pursuing
Net Zero Net Zero targets which need to
be pursued but in at an unrealistic Pace
uh leaving our energy Supply in a very
fragile state so all of those things on
a longer term basis need to be solved
um but certainly I think the government
has been very preoccupied with itself
lately
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview is still with me Jake Wallace
Simon's editor of the Jewish Chronicle
and Jenny cleeman journalist and
broadcaster welcome back to both of you
let us take a look at the financial
times and pictured on the front there
two of the uh well the European leaders
assemble for this uh security conference
should we say in uh Prague and we
noticed we haven't actually got the
shots of it but I noticed that the
family photo
Liz truss was right at the back on the
left
read into that as you will oh do we have
that do we have the family photo shot
but talk us in
to this story Jenny
uh well this is this new European Club
of Nations it was macron's idea 44
countries all of the EU Switzerland
Norway us turkey some people who some
countries that never wanted to join the
EU some that have left some that want to
join the idea is uh they all come
together to talk about
um security stability Prosperity
migration and energy security and this
is kind of Putin's worst nightmare
really uh it is amazing how much the
invasion of Ukraine has served to
Galvanize all the different parts of the
world that Vladimir Putin wanted to
cause havoc in in terms of NATO and in
terms of Europe this is beyond the EU
this is a wider Europe coming together
uh to present a united front uh I think
obviously energy security is going to be
a really big part of all of it
um as as well as uh migration and as
well as the physical security of the
rest of Europe Liz Charleston there
today she's clearly decided that macron
is a friend rather than a foe but what
is really interesting uh in terms of our
place the UK in this European Club is
the extent to which Liz truss is always
is always going on about her her key to
everything is growth growth growth and
in order to really maximize growth we
have to have a better relationship with
Europe in in many different ways but
that is the kind of antagonism at the
moment at the heart of the conservative
party when it comes to the single Market
when it comes to migration there is a
huge part of list trust's party that
wants her to pull away from Europe so
there was a lot of rhetoric when she was
appealing to conservative voters that
was quite anti-european now that she's a
leader and now that she's out there that
rhetoric is gone and she's obviously
much more comfortable talking about
energy security and Vladimir Putin than
she is on home soil talking about the
economy interesting Jake though as
Jenny's saying during the campaigning
asked whether macron was friend or fro
she said that she was undecided
um seems to have rapidly made up her
mind now though
that's right I mean the headlines that
accompanied that comment back then were
were pretty poor uh and now she seems to
have affirmed that he is a friend after
all and it does seem that on the broader
sense
um the pressure from Ukraine and from uh
Vladimir Putin's War there has caused
the Europeans on the whole to realize
they need to stick together more even
with countries with whom they might
disagree and I think on all sides they
seem to be growing up a bit and working
together as a new anglo-french Summit
that's been uh announced for next year
uh macron and Liz truss have agreed to
work together more to counter the
migrant uh disaster in the channel
um and uh and also London has been named
as the one of the uh locations for the
for a meeting of this new group the
European political Community uh in 2024
which was an announcement which was
greeted very warmly so it seems that
um cordiality has broken out a little
bit at least or at least the first hint
of it
um in Europe and further afield and this
is very very welcome for a country who's
been a little bit exasperated by seeing
our political leaders behaving like
children uh engaging in tit-for-tat uh
spiteful Warfare rather than growing up
and getting on with the jobs of being
good friends and neighbors Jenny very
quickly just tell us what uh Jacob Reese
MOG is planning
this Telegraph he wants there to be a
holiday uh for the king's coronation
which is said to be 2nd of June but it's
not been confirmed again we have a a
government that's all about growth how
could they call on a call for a new bank
holidays March Jacob Reese morgue is
very much a traditionalist of course
he's going to want everybody to have the
day off to see the king being crowned
and I've just come back from the U.S
they love all of the pageantry that we
have here potentially you know this is
very good for our economy
um having a big uh you know something to
draw in the tourists the king being
crazy and Jake thank you very much we'll
see you in the next hour thank you